le cas je le disais vous suivez l'un des
cortèges parisiens sur appel des gilets
jaunes quelle est l'ambiance
actuellement
et bien vous pouvez le voir cette
manifestation est désormais démarrer
depuis un peu plus d'une demi heure elle
est encadrée par un très important
dispositif policier comme vous pouvez le
voir sur ces images d'olivier molinari
c'est désormais la norme depuis
plusieurs manifestations alors cette
manifestation du 11 septembre elle est
très importante pour ces militants
contre le passo sanitaires car c'est le
dernier samedi avant contre en vigueur
et bien la totalité de l'obligation
vaccinale pour certaines professions à
partir donc du 15 septembre ça fait
aussi un mois depuis le 9 août que le
pass sanitaire s'impose à tous et les
mots d'ordre d'ordre restent les mêmes
nous pas sanitaire nous à la
surveillance généralisée c'est en tout
cas ce que ces personnes disent je vous
propose de les écouter
dans quelques jours le pass annie terre
va faire perdre des emplois de
nombreuses personnes
donc moi je suis pas anti pacs je suis
seulement antipas sanitaires je suis
pour la liberté chacun est là pour pour
vivre ce qu'il a à vivre et laisser les
gens décider arrêter de nous imposer des
choses dont on ne veut pas je suis pour
cette liberté d'être comment de pouvoir
choisir ce qui est bon pour nous je
lutte depuis des années à accompagner
les gens pour chercher ce qui est
beaucoup à l'intérieur d'eux qu'ils le
trouvent tout seul on va pas aller se
faire en aidant une décision qui n'est
pas la nôtre ce qui me déplaît le plus
c'est qu'on en fait on nous a pas
demandé notre avis on a des députés qui
devraient nous représenter et en tout
cas on en entend pas parler c'est à dire
que on ne pourrait faire j'ai pas moins
un référendum pourquoi les référendums
on n'en voit plus en france
les appels à manifester se sont
multipliés depuis plusieurs semaines
pour venir le 11 septembre à paris une
journée stratégique je vous propose
d'écouter ce que nous en a dit fawzi
lellouche gilet jaune que j'ai pu
rencontrer
au début de ce cortège
n'a fait un appel de façon à ce que la
france soit sur paris pour faire enlever
cette loi liberticide qui est le pass
sanitaires pour nous elle est allée
complètement contraires aux déclarations
universelles des droits de l'homme de
1789 à les contraires à la république
pour des raisons de principe déjà
d'égalité et de liberté le faire un
appel à toute la france à venir sur
paris c'est de montrer à emmanuel macron
qu'on n'ait pas une minorité il va nous
voir sur paris là où les décisions sont
prises là où les institutions sont là où
il ya tous les médias il va voir qu'il
ya du monde qui est contrôle passe
sanitaire simplement sans
même en ordre dispersé les manifestants
veulent rassembler un maximum de monde
dans la capitale vous l'avais dit il ya
quatre appels à manifester aujourd'hui à
paris est désormais le but est bien
c'est de faire plier le gouvernement
le gouvernement qui pour l'instant ne
montre aucun signe de faiblesse olivier
ferrand le ministre de la santé a
annoncé qu'il y aurait la fermeté la
plus totale contre les soignants qui
refuse toujours la vaccination ils
seront suspendus sans salaire
merci à lucas pour toutes ces précisions